Hello Freak bitches.
When I,
when I got out of high school,
um,
I went to art school for a year or two
and then I dropped out and I was just
like,
how am I going to make
a living doing this?
And I,
and I got all my best
drawings and I went to,
I think it was cal arts,
it was like a,
it's like a open call,
like in,
it's like every single animation studio,
every single advertising agency.
And I got there and it's all these fucking
kids with all their art and there's
really long lines to talk to a guy that
like has a pencil behind his ear and
goes,
work on this work on this.
And I was like,
fuck this.
And so I was like,
I'm not even going to wait in this line.
So I went and I went to go take a piss
and I saw one of the advertising guys get
up and I followed him to
the bathroom and I said,
I pulled one of those.
Well,
while his Dick's out,
I'm like,
Hey,
look at,
look at this cross hatch
penis will get this.
And he's like,
Hey,
you can't wait in line like everyone else.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm pleased.
And he like looked over and he's like,
Hey,
that's pretty good.
And so he's got his dick out and,
and a nice fat Dick Dude.
Now he gives,
he gives me his card and he goes,
you're fucking dope man.
You should come to my
office in Beverly Hills.
And I was like either 20 or 21.
And I was like,
yes.
And it's the,
it's one of the biggest
advertising agencies in La.
I show up there like with
a tie on and everything.
And as I walked down the hallway,
it's like every movie poster.
And uh,
I was like,
I made it,
I'm fucking like young and I'm
going to make a living drawing.
Like this is fucking crazy.
So I think back then,
I don't know how it is now.
They would have all these
artists draw in the style.
I forgotten drew Struzan,
that's that star wars a
painted all the star wars.
These guys all draw that same style and
you draw the movie poster and then they
give that to the photographer.
And the photographer,
because you know,
there's no art in movie posters now,
and this is,
I'm talking about fucking 20 years ago,
so I'm sure it's different now.
And it was a avalanche movie with Chris.
No,
crystal.
Donald.
Crystal Donald.
I think that the movie
was called avalanche.
Yeah.
And so I sat in the room and I was like,
this is so cool.
I get to see a movie before it came out,
you know?
And I'm like,
this movie fucking sucks.
And then I'm sitting there watching
it with like six old guys with like
cigarettes daily dangling
out of their mouth.
I'm like,
all right guys,
we need avalanches.
We need this and this.
We need Chris O'donnell looking like this.
And I'm like,
this is amazing.
You know?
And I sit in a room and I draw Chris
O'donnell and there's a poster,
vertical,
vertical limit.
There it is.
I think I drew that Bill Paxton.
Well that's what you do.
Yeah,
that's pretty exact.
Willem defoe was the guy in the back,
I don't remember who got
the Glenn Scott Glenn.
Oh,
that guy.
Yeah,
he's,
that guy is awesome.
So I got all their headshots,
I'm drawing them,
the art directors coming in and he's like,
you know,
it's amazing.
He starts with the compliment Dave.
That's great.
Can you do it again?
Like a little bit smirk,
a little bit more heroic and then,
um,
not even a day in,
I'm like,
I hate this job.
I just drew fucking crystal Donald
and same thing at the same thought.
Then I'm like,
how did this movie get made?
Right?
Like it's horrible.
Like,
like who?
like,
why don't crystal,
Donald's a beautiful man.
I just want to see him.
It's a good date night movie.
And so I already safe.
I lasted at that job,
you know,
when you say like you got to draw shit,
like yeah.
The next one was like a Sandra Bullock
movie where she's an alcoholic,
the 28 days or something and
you know that that whole like,
Hey,
I'm somewhat part of Showbiz and I'm
working and I'm making the good money.
I walked into the guy's
office less than a month in.
I said like,
thank you for this honor.
I appreciate it like this.
I learned so much I can't do it.
He's like,
what are you talking about?
Like you see that line,
you see how many people would die?
He's like,
Dave.
And he closes the door.
He was like,
I'm going to tell you something.
You remind me of me.
Like 20 years ago,
the fucking crazy hair.
You got like that fucking
punk rock attitude.
If you stay here and
you do what I tell you,
you could be running this
fucking place in like 20 years.
And I was like,
oh well you only gave me a nice ego.
Boost the devil.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
I wonder if he said this to
all those guys out there,
you know?
And because I was the
youngest guy there and I go,
I can't even believe I'm telling you.
Like,
like I said,
thank you for this opportunity.
I can't do this though.
I can't.
Like,
I feel like art is my passion.
I love it.
I feel like I'm dying here and you know,
cause I thought,
oh,
I could draw crystal Donal all day.
And then at night I could
draw whatever I want,
a or fifteens and buttholes,
but muscle memory.
I had just spent the entire day training
my hand to draw into drew Struzan style
style of Chris O'donnell.
I get home and I want to do my shit.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck that butthole looks
like crystal Donald's face,
you know?
So I tell the guy,
go,
hey look,
I can't believe this great
opportunity you gave me,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to have to re
regretfully decline this thing.
And he goes,
oh,
what are you going to do Dave?
Draw your funny books.
He didn't say it in that voice,
but he's like,
he's like,
what's like mocking?
No.
Yeah,
not like hardcore,
but he's like,
what are you going to do?
And he's like,
good luck with that.
And I was like,
you know what I,
I've made at that young at that,
it's,
it's the,
it's for me the saddest thing when I
see young people that have already like
given,
and I'm like,
that's the time you fight.
That's the time that you should
try and fail and try again.
And then it's like when you get old,
you're like,
at least I tried.
It didn't work out,
you know.
So I said,
look man,
I'm going to go for it and if
I end up fucking broke or poor,
whatever,
then fuck it,
you know,
at least I tried,
you know?
And,
and the next next job from
that was drawing a midgets and,
and,
and bottles for Hustler.
So I was like,
yes,
I get to at least draw what I want
to draw and buttholes for Hustler.
Yeah.
Worked for like Asian fever and the
whole Larry Flynt trying to monetize a
creative vision.
It's always,
it's really important that you try to
figure out what is unique in your head and
that what is in your head and if you,
how do you get it out?
And if you want to bring up
the Chappelle show or anything,
it's like this whole like,
like I don't want to start my own network.
I don't want to start my
own publishing company.
It's like I'm just going
to do whatever I want,
knowing that it's not
gonna make any money.
And then what always happens is
because it's so unique and whatever,
it does make money.
Oh,
that's so easy for you now Dave,
cause you have fuck you money.
I'm like,
how do you think I got it?
How do you think I fucking got it right?
It does.
You like to still be
working for that advertiser,
right,
exactly.
I take the chance when I had
nothing and I had nothing to nude,
they say the rich and the poor have more
in common than the middle class because
they both like if you're poor,
you're like,
hey,
I got nothing to lose.
If I get sued or whatever,
I'm like,
they could take my fucking
toilet paper roll or whatever,
you know?
So I dunno.
Okay.